- The moment we have all
been waiting and eagerly
is finally here with us!
- C'est le coup d'envoi
attendu pour une planète
qui ne peut plus attendre.
Le marathon de la COP15
est officiellement parti.
- Humanity has become
a weapon of mass extinction.
- "L'humanité est
devenue une arme de
destruction massive", a lancé
Antonio Guterres a a appelant
les négociateurs du monde entier
à ne pas se laisser berner
par les puissants lobbys.
ANTONIO GUTERRES, secrétaire
général des Nations unies
- Oublions les rêveries
de certains milliardaires :
il n'y a pas de planète B.
C'est à nous de réparer
le monde que nous avons.
Je vous en conjure,
faites ce qu'il faut,
agissez pour ltututure.
(applaudissements)
- Justin Trudeau en a profit
pour annoncer que le Canada
donnera 350 millions de dollars
pour la protection
de la biodiversité
à l'international.
- And filled with
unexpected life.
- Une annonce interrompue...
hahahants et tambours)
... par une manifestation
impromptue. Un rappel que
les peuples autochtones
sont les plus touchés
par la perte de biodiversité
et que dans un effort sincère
de réconciliation, le Canada
a un devoir ésésésultat.
Le premier ministre du Québec
a, pour sa part, annoncé
l'élaboration d'un plan nature
avec une enveloppe de
650 millions de dollars.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT
premier ministre du Québec
- Je prends l'engagement
aujourd'hui devant tout le monde
de tout mettre oeuvre pour
atteindre une protection
du territoire québécois
à 30 % d'ici 2030.
- Voilà, passer de la parole
aux actes.
- De belles paroles, mais qui
doivent enfin se concrétiser,
croit cet homm
FIDELE RUZIGANDEKWE, Collabor.
transfrontalière du Virunga
- Nous voulions voir sur
le terrain des actions
concrètes, des actions réelles
où la biodiversité est protégée.
- Parce que pour certains,
comme Anni-Sofia,
son identité en dépend.
En 1987, on signait l'Accord
de Montréal pour la protection
de la couche d'ozone, un accord
historique qui a porté fruit.
35 ans plus tard, dansmêmêmême
En 1987, on signait l'Accord
de Montréal pour la protection
de la couche d'ozone, un accord
historique qui a porté fruit.
35 ans plus tard, dans la même
ville, peut-on réécrire
l'histoire? Pour l'instant,
tous les scénarios
sont envisageables.
Ici Élisa Serret,
Radio-Canada, Montréa